i haven't really had a relationship in
the past 20 years or so
all right hang up okay
oh it's leaking here oh sorry about that
a little bit
in high school i had a
somewhat of a serious relationship
it was for about a year
that pretty much sums it up
he's very good nation that's what i love
about him happy good kid
i'm not a kid anymore pop yeah i know
i was always looking for a serious
relationship
someone to just settle down with
so
since i went 34 years without finding a
woman in my local area i just decided to
change my location in a dating
application and just switch it over to
columbia
and i met someone that made my dreams
come true
[Music]
my girlfriend's name is jimena she's 24
years old and she lives in parada
colombia and she's the most beautiful
woman in the world
when i first got the notification that i
met i swiped right i was just like wow
is this really happening i had to like
pinch myself
ximena and i have been talking for about
a year now and
i feel like i know
men are
fairly well thank you
and um even though we've never
physically met before
she's the first person that i truly feel
like i fell in love with
[Music]